SENATE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE ONE
TO ORDER, AND WE HAVE A QUORUM
AND ASK TO PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR LEONARD HERE. SENATOR
QUOTESI HERE. SENATOR WILK
PRESENT, EVERYBODY IS HERE, AND
WE HAVE A QUORUM, TODAY IS OUR
NINTH AND FINAL SUBCOMMITTEE
HEARING ON EDUCATION ISSUES FOR
2024, SINCE FEBRUARY THREE, THE
SUBCOMMITTEE HELD EXTENSIVE,
EXTENSIVE DISCUSSION ON ALL
ISSUES ACROSS PRE-K THROUGH 12
AND HIGHER EDUCATION. AND AFTER
HISTORIC AND UNPRECEDENTED
LEVELS OF FUNDING FOR EDUCATION
ON ALL LEVELS, WE'VE HAD TO
PIVOT AND FACE DIFFICULT
DECISIONS THAT ARE REQUIRED IN
THE CONTEXT OF A VERY SERIOUS
BUDGET SHORTFALL. IN A MOMENT,
WE WILL TAKE UP VOTE ONLY
CALENDARS FOR PART A, WHICH IS
PRE-K THROUGH 12, AND PART B ON
HIGHER EDUCATION, THE AGENDA
REFLECTS A LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE SENATE AND
THE ASSEMBLY, WHICH IS A
RESPONSIBLE PLAN THAT PROTECTS
AGAINST SOME OF THE MORE HARMFUL
CUTS THAT WERE RECOMMENDED TO
CORE PROGRAMS. AND WE DID THAT
AFTER TAKING MUCH STAKEHOLDER
FEEDBACK IN THIS PROCESS. AND WE
APPRECIATE, WHAT PEOPLE SAID AND
WERE HELPFUL AS WE WENT INTO
DEPTH ON EACH OF THESE ISSUES.
SO LET ME JUST VERY BRIEFLY
SUMMARIZE SOME OF THE TOP POINTS
OF WHAT IS IN THE BUDGET. WE
WILL CONSIDER FOR AND IN MY
VIEW, HOPE TO APPROVE TODAY. THE
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET INCREASES
PROPOSITION 98 OVERALL BY $1.9
BILLION. IT WOULD BE A TOTAL
INCREASE OF $1 BILLION, OR 1.07.
COLA FOR THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA THAT GOES TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS, CHARTERS AND
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION.
THIS WOULD FUND AN INCREASE OF
$318 MILLION TO FULLY MEET OUR
OBLIGATIONS TO FUND UNIVERSAL
SCHOOL MEALS. IT LEAVES A
BALANCE IN PROPOSITION 98
RESERVE AFTER THE 20 2425 YEAR
IN HIGHER EDUCATION, IT WOULD
GIVE UC AND CSU A BASE INCREASE
FOR 20 2425, A NET INCREASE TO
EACH SYSTEM BY FUNDING THE 20
2425 5% BASE INCREASES FOR UC
AND CSU, FOREGOING THE DEFERRAL
THAT HAD BEEN IN THE EARLY
ACTION AGREEMENT AND PROPOSED BY
THE GOVERNOR, IN EARLIER THIS
YEAR. AND IT ALSO WOULD NOT CUT
Kò INSTITUTES. WE WOULD REJECT
CUTS TO THE UC LABOR CENTERS AND
UCLA LATINO POLICY AND POLITICS
INSTITUTE ON FINANCIAL AID. IT
WOULD RESTORE FULL FUNDING FOR
THE MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP
PROGRAM. IT WOULD IMPLEMENT A
MODIFIED CAL GRANT REFORM, WHICH
WILL BENEFIT LOWER INCOME
STUDENTS. IT WOULD PROVIDE $20
MILLION IN PROPOSITION 98
GENERAL FUND, ONE TIME TO ASSIST
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FINANCIAL AID
OFFICES WITH THE EXPECTED DELAYS
DUE TO THE FAFSA. SITUACIÓN
ACTION AND ON COMMUNITY COLLEGES
. THE LEGISLATURE'S PLAN KEEPS
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FUNDING INTACT
AND MAKES NO CUTS. SO COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WILL RECEIVE A COLA FOR
APPORTIONMENT AND CATEGORICAL
PROGRAMS, AND PROCESS WISE,
TODAY, WE HAVE ESTABLISHED A
QUORUM. WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
PUBLIC COMMENT. WE'LL SEE IF
THERE'S ANY FINAL COMMENTS FROM
SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS. AND THEN
WE WILL GO TO THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR ON ITEMS THAT ARE IN
FRONT OF US. AND SO LET ME AND
IF YOU'RE LISTENING IN THE
HALLWAY AND YOU INTEND TO DO
PUBLIC COMMENT, COME IN RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE I AM GOING TO DO
JUST A BRIEF SHOW OF HANDS OF
WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN PUBLIC
COMMENT. 1234556. SO THEN I'M
GOING TO LIMIT THE PUBLIC
COMMENT TO THOSE SIX PEOPLE. I'M
GOING TO ALLOW UP TO ONE MINUTE
EACH. I'M GOING TO LET EVERYBODY
KNOW THAT THEY CAN. DO YOU WANT
TO SPEAK IN PUBLIC COMMENT.
OKAY, I JUST TOOK A POLL AND YOU
WEREN'T IN IT. SO I'LL CHANGE IT
TO SEVEN, SO I'LL ALLOW SEVEN
PEOPLE UP TO WHAT, ONE MINUTE
EACH. AND YOU CAN CONTACT THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE THROUGH THE WEB
PAGE OR BY LETTER TO, TO REVISE
AND EXTEND YOUR COMMENTS. OR IF
YOU'RE LISTENING AND YOU WISH TO
HAVE COMMENTS AND YOU DIDN'T DO
IT. SO WE WERE GOING TO GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT NOW. AND IF THOSE
SEVEN WOULD LINE UP, I'M GOING
TO ALLOW UP TO ONE MINUTE EACH,
ON THE ITEMS THAT ARE HERE TODAY
. SOMEHOW, WHEN I ASKED FOR
HANDS, FIVE OF YOU Ó UNLESS
YOU'RE LEAVING, FIVE OF YOU
DIDN'T RAISE YOUR HANDS. WHEN I
ASKED FOR WHO WAS GOING TO SPEAK
IN PUBLIC COMMENT. THAT WAS NOT
HELPFUL, SO I'LL JUST SEE HOW
THIS GOES. BECAUSE WE'RE TRYING
TO MOVE THIS MEETING, BUT GO UP
TO ONE, MEETING AND IT'LL BE A
YEAR BEFORE WE HAVE OTHER
MEETINGS. BUT JUST REMEMBER,
WHEN I ASK YOU TO RAISE YOUR
HAND, I ACTUALLY MEANT WOULD YOU
RAISE YOUR HAND SO I KNOW THAT'S
THE POINT. A BUNCH OF PEOPLE SAT
THERE AND WERE INTENDING TO DO
IT WITHOUT TELLING US. SO GO
RIGHT AHEAD. WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. GENE HURST HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE SANTA
CLARA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS, THE URBAN COUNTIES
OF CALIFORNIA AND THE RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA, WE WANT TO EXPRESS
OUR APPRECIATION TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR REJECTING THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL ON
EXCESSIVE RAF AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS, AND APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH US AND TALK WITH US ABOUT
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HI. KATIE
HARDEMAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION. JUST
WANTED TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT
FOR THE ADMINISTRATION'S
ALTERNATIVE PROP 98 AGREEMENT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING, MR. CHAIRMAN. AND
MEMBERS. CHRISTINA DICARO
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
LIBRARY ASSOCIATION. WE
RECOGNIZE THESE ARE VERY, VERY
DIFFICULT TIMES. WE WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR FIGHTING. FOR WHAT
TO SAVE WHAT YOU COULD OF THE
LUNCH AT THE LIBRARY PROGRAM.
THIS IS THE PROGRAM FEEDING
CHILDREN AND TEENS DURING THE
SUMMER MONTHS AT THE LIBRARY. WE
KNOW THAT THERE WILL BE SOME
LIBRARIES WHO WILL HAVE TO DROP
OUT OF THIS PROGRAM DUE TO THESE
CUTS. AND WE HOPE THAT WHEN THE
ECONOMY IMPROVES, WE CAN LOOK AT
RESTORING THE LUNCH PROGRAM ON
THE CALIFORNIA LIBRARY SERVICES
ACT REDUCTION. YOU HEARD FROM
MANY LIBRARY SUPPORTERS ON THIS
ITEM. IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO
THEIR LIBRARY PATRONS. THEY'RE
DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE CUT
HERE BECAUSE IT WILL IMPACT
ACCESS TO LIBRARY COLLECTIONS
FOR EVERYBODY IN THE STATE.
AGAIN, WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU IN THE COMING
MONTHS AND YEARS IN TERMS OF
TRYING TO REBUILD THIS PROGRAM
AS WELL. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, PRISCILLA.
KUDOS HERE ON BEHALF OF ADVANCE
ENERGY UNITED. WE JUST WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THE IMPORTANCE OF
FULLY FUNDING ZERO EMISSION
SCHOOL BUSSES BY APPROVING THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION PROPOSAL
IN THAT AREA. AS YOU KNOW,
CALIFORNIA HAS ONE OF THE OLDEST
SCHOOL BUS FLEETS IN THE NATION.
OLD INTERNAL COMBUSTION ENGINE
SCHOOL BUSSES POLLUTE THE AIR
AND ENDANGER CHILDREN'S HEALTH.
MANY SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
DECIDING WHICH BUSSES TO
PURCHASE TODAY, AND EACH SCHOOL
BUS CAN BE ON THE ROAD FOR OVER
15 YEARS. DISADVANTAGED
DISTRICTS WITH TIGHT BUDGETS
NEED SUPPORT TO BE ABLE TO
AFFORD CLEAN BUSSES, SO WE MUST
ENSURE THAT THE NECESSARY
FUNDING THIS YEAR SO THAT
THEY'RE NOT STUCK WITH POLLUTING
BUSSES FOR THE NEXT 15 YEARS. WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT YOU
APPROVE THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISION PROPOSAL AND FULLY FUND
ZERO EMISSION SCHOOL BUSSES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING. HEATHER KHAMIS
FROM EDVOICE, REGARDING ITEM
NUMBER 17, THE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR EDUCATORS OF
UNIVERSAL TO ADMINISTRATE,
ADMINISTRATE, UNIVERSAL
SCREENING BEGINNING IN 2526. WE
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S
COMMITMENT TO ENSURING THAT
TEACHERS HAVE THE TOOLS AND
TRAINING AND RESOURCES TO HIT
THE GROUND RUNNING, BEGINNING IN
THE 2025 2026 SCHOOL YEAR.
REGARDING ITEM NUMBER 48, WHICH
IS THE GOLDEN STATE TEACHER
GRANT PROGRAM, WE APPRECIATE AND
SUPPORT THE RECOMMENDATION TO
REJECT THE PROPOSED FISCAL
REDUCTIONS IN THE CURRENT
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
SIGNIFICANTLY DILUTE THE INTENT
AND IMPACT OF THE PROGRAM AND
ACTIONS SUCH AS REDUCING THE
AWARD AMOUNTS OR DECREASING THE
TIME THAT TEACHERS ARE REQUIRED
TO WORK IN A PRIORITY SCHOOL,
DECREASES THE OVERALL INCENTIVE
FOR POTENTIAL TEACHERS TO WORK
IN THOSE PRIORITY SCHOOLS IN THE
FIRST PLACE. SO AGAIN,
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. HELLO. MY NAME IS CHAD
ZELINGER. I'M PRESIDENT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA MUSIC EDUCATORS
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING 1700
MEMBERS ACROSS THE STATE, THANK
YOU, THANK YOU FOR READING OUR
LETTER. AT THE LAST MEETING. I
APPRECIATE THAT, SO KI¾M AGREES
WITH REJECTING ITEM 107 ON PAGE
23 FROM THE CTE. CTE TEACHER
SUPPLEMENTARY AUTHORIZATION FOR
ART, MUSIC, DANCE AND THEATER AS
WELL AS OTHER PROVISIONS IN THE
ITEM 107, WE REQUEST THAT THE
COMMITTEE'S REJECTION OF ITEM
107 AS WELL OUR MEMBERS. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. AND THE BUDGET
STAFF FOR LISTENING TO OUR
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS REGARDING
THIS PROPOSAL. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WELCOME JASON
WHISTLER, SENIOR RESEARCH
SPECIALIST WITH UC DAVIS LABOR
CENTER. I SPOKE HERE A COUPLE OF
WEEKS AGO AGAINST THE PROPOSED
CUTS TO THE LABOR CENTERS. SO
TODAY I'M HERE TO SHOW MY
APPRECIATION AND SAY THANK YOU
FOR REJECTING THOSE CUTS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS. ANDREA.
PAUL, FIRST, ON BEHALF OF THE
SUBURBAN SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION, THE CENTRAL VALLEY
EDUCATION COALITION, I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR ALL THE WORK
YOU'VE DONE THIS YEAR,
ESPECIALLY FOR FUNDING THE COST
OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT, MAKING
SURE THAT'S IN THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ACROSS THE STATE. ON THE GOLDEN
STATE TEACHER AWARD ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGISTS, WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU REJECTING THE
CHANGES. THAT PROGRAM WAS
RECENTLY CHANGED TO ALLOW FOLKS
GETTING THEIR PUPIL SERVICES
CREDENTIAL, WHICH INCLUDES
SCHOOL PSYCHOLOGISTS, AND WE
REALLY THINK THE CUTS WOULD BE
DEVASTATING. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. WELCOME HELLO, MR. CHAIR,
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE,
YVONNE FERNANDEZ WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION HERE
TO VOICE OUR APPRECIATION FOR
THE PROTECTION OF èC LABOR
CENTER FUNDING, AS WELL AS THE
PROTECTION OF FUNDING FOR THE
UCLA LATINO POLICY AND POLITICS
INSTITUTE. WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE'S
DECISION TO PROTECT THIS
FUNDING. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, TIFFANY.
MARK, CFT, THANK YOU, CHAIR,
MEMBERS AND STAFF FOR YOUR HARD
WORK ON THIS BUDGET. WE WANTED
TO SUPPORT THE REJECTION OF THE
CUTS TO THE LABOR CENTER, THE
PROPOSAL FOR 100% OFFICE HOURS
FOR PART TIME FACULTY. IT'S
REALLY KEY TO STUDENT LEARNING
AND PROVIDING EQUITY OF
OPPORTUNITY TO MAXIMIZE STUDENT
RESEARCH, OPPORTUNITY OF
LEARNING. THE PROPOSAL FOR
ALTERNATIVE, THE ALTERNATIVE
PROPOSAL FOR PROP 98, AND ALSO
THE THOUGHTFULNESS IN FUNDING
THE UC COMPACT FOR THIS COMING
YEAR. WE OPPOSE CUTS TO THE UC
GENERALLY, SO I'D LIKE TO NOTE
THAT AS WELL. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
MORNING, MR. CHAIR, AND MEMBERS
AND STAFF, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
WORKING WITH US THIS YEAR AND
READING OUR LETTERS AND
REPORTING BACK ON OUR LETTERS.
WE APPRECIATE THAT. WANTED TO
ALIGN MYSELF WITH THE COMMENTS
OF THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER. REMIND
US WHO YOU ARE. OH, SORRY.
PAMELA GIBBS PAMELA GIBBS
REPRESENTING LOS ANGELES COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION. I KNOW, BUT
THE PEOPLE AT HOME MIGHT NOT
EXACTLY. THANK YOU, SENATOR, FOR
REMINDING ME. I'M TRYING TO GET
RIGHT IN AND GET RIGHT OUT, SO I
APPRECIATE THAT. I WON'T
INTERRUPT YOU ANYMORE. WELL,
AGAIN, I WANT TO ALIGN MYSELF
WITH THE PREVIOUS SPEAKER
RELATED TO THE GOLDEN STATE
TEACHER GRANT PROGRAM. WE
APPRECIATE PUTTING THE FUNDING
BACK IN FOR THAT. AND ALSO ON
ITEM 21 AND 22 FOR THE K-12 HIGH
SPEED NETWORK AND THE BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE. IT'S A COUNTY
WIDE PRIORITY FOR LACOE. AND SO
WE URGE YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT
FOR THAT. ALSO FOR COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS, WHICH IS THE LAST ONE
I'LL TALK ABOUT. THANK YOU FOR
EXTENDING THAT DEADLINE FOR
FUNDING. IT'S BEEN A PRIORITY
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTY AS WELL,
AND WE'LL SEND AN UPDATED
LETTER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
GOOD LUCK TODAY. THANK YOU.
WELCOME. KEN JACOBS, CO-CHAIR,
UC BERKELEY LABOR CENTER. AND
JUST WANT TO EXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION FOR YOU, FOR YOUR
REJECTING THE CUTS TO THE UC
LABOR CENTERS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WE APPRECIATE
THAT. GOOD AFTERNOON. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, SABA WAHID, UCLA LABOR
CENTER. ALSO WANT TO EXPRESS MY
GRATITUDE FOR COMMITTEE FOR
CONTINUING THE FUNDING OF THE UC
LABOR CENTERS, IT WILL ALLOW US
TO DO THE RESEARCH AND EDUCATION
PROGRAMS, AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. HI. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE, KELLY
LONGO FLORES WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS. WE
WORK ALONGSIDE 41 FOOD BANKS
ACROSS THE STATE WITH A MISSION
TO END HUNGER. AND WE'RE JUST
HERE TO SAY A HUGE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF FULLY FUNDING
SCHOOL MEALS FOR ALL, IN YOUR
BUDGET PACKAGE. WE KNOW THAT 1
IN 4 CALIFORNIA FAMILIES FACE
FOOD INSECURE, AND THIS IS AN
ESSENTIAL PROGRAM. SO BIG. THANK
YOU. AND ALSO A ME A ME TOO. ON
BEHALF OF GRACE IN CHILD
POVERTY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI. GOOD MORNING, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. OVERALL WE'RE VERY
APPRECIATIVE FOR OH I SHOULD
START WITH MY INTRODUCTION. YES.
THANK YOU. CAROL GONZALEZ HERE
ON BEHALF OF A FEW FOLKS, HOPE
HISPANAS ORGANIZED FOR POLITICAL
EQUALITY, THEY'RE VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE INCLUSION OF
THE UC LABOR CENTERS AND THE
INCLUSION OF THE UNSEEN LATINAS
INITIATIVE. THAT WAS VERY
IMPORTANT TO THEM, SECOND,
INCLUSIVE ACTION FOR THE CITY.
ALSO APPRECIATIVE OF THE UCLA
LABOR CENTER. AND THEN ED TRUST
WEST, THEY'RE APPRECIATIVE OF
THE CSU AND UC COMPACT AND THE
INCLUSION OF CAL GRANT REFORM.
VERY IMPORTANT AND LONG BEACH
CITY COLLEGE, VERY APPRECIATIVE
OF THE COLA. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THAT
COMPLETES OUR PUBLIC COMMENT.
THANKS, EVERYONE, FOR, MAKING
THE COMMENTS. WE APPRECIATE IT.
AND WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO THE
COMMITTEE. AND SO FIRST I'M
GOING TO OFFER MY COLLEAGUES A
CHANCE TO MAKE ANY COMMENTS
BEFORE WE MOVE TO A VOTE.
SENATOR CORTEZ, DO YOU HAVE
ANYTHING YOU'D LIKE TO SAY? I
APPRECIATE IT VERY MUCH. THE
PUBLIC COMMENT, AND OF COURSE,
GIVEN, MY HOME COUNTY AND ONE OF
YOUR HOME COUNTIES, PARTICULARLY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE REJECTION OF
THE Â RALPH, PROPOSAL. SO I
DON'T HAVE MUCH MORE TO SAY.
I'VE BEEN PLAYING CATCH UP WITH
A LOT OF EXCELLENT HELP FROM
THIS COMMITTEE STAFF OVER THE
LAST TWO WEEKS, AND I THINK I'M
PREPARED TO, MOVE ITEMS WHEN THE
TIME IS APPROPRIATE. GREAT. I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS, AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS
TO SERVE SO LATE IN THE SESSION.
I'M JUST GOING TO DO THIS ALL AT
ONCE IN READING, BUT WE'LL
ENTERTAIN THREE SEPARATE MOTIONS
IN VOTE ONLY, AND WE'RE GOING TO
DO PART A AND B TOGETHER IN ONE
MOTION IN THESE DIFFERENT THREE
MOTIONS. AND SO JUST FOR THE
RECORD, THE FIRST MOTION WOULD
BE ON PART A ISSUES SIX, SEVEN,
11, 13, 15 TO 21, 24 TO 25, 27
TO 31, 33, 35 TO 46, 48 TO 49,
51 TO 57, 59 TO 72, 79, 81 TO
90, 94 TO 96, 99 TO 104, 106 TO
109, AND THEN IN PART B IN UNDER
THIS SAME MOTION WOULD BE ISSUES
2 TO 10, 1214 TO 17, 19 TO 20,
22 TO 27, 28, 31 TO 32, 22 TO
20. EXCUSE ME, I'M RUSHING TOO
MUCH. 22 TO 24. 28, 31 TO 32. 34
TO 35, 38 TO 40, 42 TO 44, 46 TO
47 AND 49 TO 50. SO I WOULD
ENTERTAIN A MOTION. WILK WILK
MOVES THE MOTION. OKAY, MOTION
FOR THOSE ITEMS TO APPROVE A
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
LEONARD. AYE. SENATOR. LEONARD.
AYE. SENATOR CORTESE. AYE, AYE.
SENATOR WILK. AYE. SENATOR WILK.
AYE. THAT MOTION IS APPROVED ON
A30 VOTE. THEN THE SECOND MOTION
WILL BE FOR PART A ISSUES 1 TO
5, EIGHT, TEN, 22, 26, 34, 47,
73, 79, EIGHT, 76, 80, 91, 93,
97 AND 98 AND UNDER PART B,
ISSUES ONE, 11, 13, 18, 21, 25
TO 27, 29 TO 30, 33, 36, AND 37,
45 AND 48. DO I HAVE A MOTION?
I'M WILLING TO MOVE THAT, PART A
AND PART B SET OF ITEMS MOTION,
BY SENATOR CORTESE ON THE ISSUES
I READ. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR LAIRD. AYE. LAIRD. AYE.
SENATOR. CORTESE. AYE. CORTESE
AYE. SENATOR WILK. NÓ. WILK. NO.
THAT MOTION CARRIES 2 TO 1, AND
THEN WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO A
THIRD MOTION. AND BY THE WAY,
THANK YOU, EVERYBODY IS CLEARLY
FOLLOWING ALONG. SO, I
APPRECIATE THAT, AND THE THIRD
MOTION WOULD INCLUDE UNDER PART
A ISSUES. 912 1423 3250, 58, 74
TO 75, 77 TO 78, 92, 105 AND
UNDER PART B, ISSUE 41, DO I
HAVE A MOTION MOVE APPROVAL
MOTION BY SENATOR CORTEZ? PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR LAIRD.
AYE. LAIRD. AYE. SENATOR CORTEZ
A CORTESE. AYE. SENATOR WILK
WILK NOT VOTING. OKAY. THANK
YOU. THAT MOTION CARRIES TWO, TO
ZERO. AND SO, LET ME. THAT
COMPLETES OUR BUSINESS CASE, BUT
I'M GOING TO MAKE ONE CLOSING
COMMENT BECAUSE A LOT OF THE
PEOPLE THAT WERE TESTIFYING WERE
BEGINNING TO CELEBRATE. AND LET
ME JUST TELL YOU, THIS IS A WAY
STATION IN THE PROCESS, AND
THERE WILL BE THREE PARTY
NEGOTIATIONS. WE ARE HOPEFUL
THAT THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE
APPROVING A SIMILAR LIST TODAY
THAT WILL CREATE A LEGISLATIVE
BUDGET THAT MIGHT COME TO A
FLOOR VOTE AS THAT IS. BUT IF
THERE ARE THREE PARTY
NEGOTIATIONS AND THEY'RE
SUCCESSFUL, THEN THERE MIGHT BE
A MORE FULL BUDGET THAT COMES
BEFORE JUNE 15TH. IF NOT, WE
WILL LIKELY ADDRESS THE BUDGET
WE JUST PASSED BEFORE JUNE 15TH,
AND THEN HAVE A FINAL SET OF
BUDGET ACTIONS THAT WOULD BE
TAKEN BEFORE JUNE 30TH. MAYBE
JUNE, BY JUNE 27TH. SO I JUST
ASK THAT YOU ALL, KEEP ON THIS
BECAUSE ALL OF YOU HAVE
DIFFERENT CONCERNS AND THIS HAS
BEEN AMAZING PROGRESS FROM THE
JANUARY 10TH BUDGET TO ALL OUR
HEARINGS TO THE MAY REVISE,
WHICH INCORPORATED A BUNCH OF
THINGS TO THE MORE LEGISLATIVE
FOCUSED BUDGET WHERE WE JUST
ADOPTED THE EDUCATION PART OF IT
AND OTHER SUBCOMMITTEES ARE
ACTING RIGHT NOW TO DO THE
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE BUDGET,
WHICH WILL ROLL UP INTO ONE
COMPLETE BUDGET AND WE ARE
UNIQUE IN THE EDUCATION BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE BECAUSE OF
PROPOSITION 98 AND SOME OF THE
OTHER FACTORS THAT REALLY TALK
ABOUT REVENUES IN A DIFFERENT
WAY THAN THE OTHER
SUBCOMMITTEES. AND SO YOU CAN
SEE A LITTLE MORE CLEARLY HOW
THE REVENUE MATCHES THE
EXPENDITURES HERE. BUT IT'S THE
OVERALL ARCHITECTURE OF THE
BUDGET THAT WILL DICTATE WHAT
THE OTHER SUBCOMMITTEES ARE
DOING RIGHT NOW. AND IT DID
INFLUENCE WHAT WE DID ON THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
CAL STATE UNIVERSITY SYSTEM. SO
WITH THAT, SEEING NO OTHER
COMMENTS, I APPRECIATE
EVERYBODY'S LONG WORK. AND EVEN
THOUGH I ANNOUNCED IT WAS THE
LAST HEARING, DON'T BE SURPRISED
IF YOU SEE US SOMETIME AGAIN.
AND I WOULD THANK THE STAFF, WHO
WAS VERY HEROIC. I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE. I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE INPUT FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION, AND MANY STAKEHOLDERS
WHO PARTICIPATED ALL THE WAY
THROUGH THE PROCESS. AND SO WITH
THAT, THE SENATE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE, ONE ON EDUCATION
WILL STAND ADJOURNED.